[Music]
Edmund Tran here here with Oscar dais at
e3 2018 and now III has a lot of
surprises usually and one of them was
this strange little game called the
awesome Adventures of Captain Spirit
Oscar what is this so it's not life is
strange - which is what I thought I was
gonna be seeing but it's actually the
awesome Adventures of Captain Spirit
which is kind of a prequel spin-off that
it's like a standalone game that is free
it's out on 26th of June Xbox one ps4 PC
yeah
and it's set in the life of strange
universe and Square Enix kind of
described to us by saying you're gonna
be seeing some hints and nods to the
original life of strange yeah and - life
is strange - yes obviously is coming at
some point but it's it's own thing it
stars Chris who's this 10 year old kid
who loves superheroes and he wants to be
a superhero and he thinks of himself as
a superhero and it becomes clear that
him and his family have got some issues
that his mum doesn't seem to be around
who knows what happened to his dad isn't
the perfect human being and so Chris
kind of uses his imagination to fill in
his world because there's not a lot
going up going on in his world he lives
in the middle of the woods it's snowy he
goes out and he plays and he pretends
he's a superhero so one of the new
things for this that will presumably
carry over - like - strange - is the
quest list now there's like a there's
like a superhero checklist yeah it's
like a placard of things that you can do
in the world that you're like oh I
wonder I wonder what that's like I could
I could go and explore like making a
suit for myself and there's all sorts of
choices like they demo to us that you
can choose whether or not you want to
have Hemi are heavy armor or light armor
you can choose whether you want to have
a helmet or not and then you have that
will change what things you have to go
out and do in the world whether you have
to go and make a helmet out of tinfoil
or not another really interesting thing
about it was that because of his
imagination you can use I think it was
left trigger to trigger like super
interaction objects in the world so like
it is not every object just
it will have like a special icon on it
and you can hold that trigger and then
press a your X or whatever button is
that you're gonna be pressing and he
will use his imagination to create a
completely different interaction with
that object so the example or a prime
example of that was there's a closet
where the the water heater is in his
house and he wants go in there and turn
the water off
yeah but he's scared of the dark and
it's dark in the closet and so he has to
go and make himself a costume so that he
can become captain spirit and then you
hold left trigger and press a and then
finally you can you can actually go in
there and he can face his demons and it
is literally like a demon inside like
because he has such an active
imagination and a lot of this is like
sort of he's sort of like crude drawings
and sort of the the crayons a cardboard
armor stuff but when he does something
like big like this it sort of switches
to a parallel universe
a more fantastical universe which makes
these of jarring cut back to reality all
the more sort of jarring I guess yeah a
bit depressing also then this is a life
of strange game so they're gonna be ups
and downs yeah yeah for sure they told
us that it's a couple of hours long like
we said it's free I think it's really
cool they're doing it I don't really
know why they've said that there's gonna
be a lot of replayability even this so
obviously you can do all that superhero
stuff you can also just not you could
just like be a kid or just like spend
the time playing with your toys alright
so the whole thing takes place over
Saturday morning and at some point it
will end and they're encouraging people
to sort of go back and sort of see what
other things you can do and what other
things you can learn because apparently
there will be some sort of link between
your save here and your saving life is
strange to over all that I thought was
really interesting I'm looking forward
to seeing more you could say it was an
awesome adventure it was an awesome
adventure Oscar and for more awesome
adventures you can stay tuned to guess
but calm or more from e3 and the
lightest change universe
you